the fastest way to accomplish any goal
is to model success find someone who's
already accomplished what you want to do
and copy what work for them and make it
work for you otherwise you're going to
end up spending tons of time energy
dollars going in the wrong direction
beating your head against the table and
you can end up frustrated and angry when
I had my first business was a software
company and it took us so long to get
going it took us so long to get
customers and to build awareness and
traction and we thought this shouldn't
be that hard we're smart people we've
got a great product why is this so hard
why is it taking so long to get going
and one day I realized you know what I'm
not the first guy to try to sell
software before and I looked at one of
the biggest companies in the world
Microsoft and looked at how they got
started I figured if they can make it
work I've got to find a way to make the
work too and look at how Bill Gates
turned his idea into making his first
million dollars I don't care how Bill
Gates makes actually million dollars now
but I didn't go from zero to one that
was interesting for me and he did it
through partnerships find someone who's
already selling to your target market
and find a way to make them help promote
your product so today but work for Bill
Gates I'm gonna try to make it work for
me you know what I had nothing else to
lose at that time because we were not
moving and I remember contacting a whole
bunch of companies and one of the first
deals that i started working on was with
a company in the UK and it was a great
potential fit for us they had offices
all around Europe could help promote our
product put us on the map there and I
just wanted them to say yes and when
they asked me their terms I remember
also adding in that they would have to
pay us 13 thousand dollars up front for
the right to represent us and it wasn't
sure if I should put that in or not kind
of a bold move but whatever you know I
had nothing to lose and so I sent it I
didn't sleep much that night because I I
doubted myself should I put that in
because really I just wanted to work
with them and the next day an email came
in and we all kind of huddled around my
laptop we're hoping for a good response
and they said let's do it and I closed
my first deal with thirteen thousand
dollars extra on our bank account and
that's not a lot of money now but that
meant a lot about meant a lot to
boss at the start you know that kept us
going that breathe new life into our
business and it could have been so much
easier if we'd only done this sooner by
mall in sex acts so whatever goal you
have with your business whatever
challenge you're facing right now
somebody has already solved it model the
success that they've had make the work
for your business good luck